[MUSIC]
Offline compared to online retail is still
actually a very large faction of consumer
spending.
So, although online is growing quite
dramatically, as of now essentially still
about 90% of retail spending
happens in the offline world.
And firms are still trying to figure
out how to best promote products,
how to best run a price promotions,
things of that sort.
And so, we wanted to go back and
see, can we actually use tools
that we learned about in the online world,
better types of measurement.
And can we bring that back to the offline
world, and try to track things better?
[MUSIC]
So we know if I run an ad online,
I typically can track,
did somebody click on it, did they again
go to my website, how much they spend.
All this linkage is much closer, and
those are often things that we
don't observe in the offline world.
Right, so an online retailer would know,
how did this consumer get to
the product he ultimately purchased?
We can observe their browsing
with a lot of precision,
offline there's usually no equivalent.
Traditionally, we weren't able to see
how did somebody walk through the store?
How did they actually get to the specific
aisle, where they then picked up products?
And so,
what we do in the study is we actually
bring in a new measurement tool that's
going to mimic the way we can observe
things online, in the offline world.
And in particular what we
going to do is we're going to rig
consumer shopping carts,
if you will, with so
called radio frequency identification tags
which work like a GPS tracker, that allow
us to track exactly how does somebody
walk through the store, which categories.
Do they walk past,
what do they eventually end up purchasing?
[MUSIC]
If in a particular week the supermarket
is running a beer add do more people
buy beer?
That we were usually able
to observe even before, but
now we can also see that actually
more people go to the beer isle.
So, did that advertising attract people
to go to different part of the store that
they wouldn't have otherwise gone to,
and then they made the purchase?
If that's true,
then maybe this advertising will have
positive spillovers to other categories.
Maybe people on their way to the beer
aisle are now going to pick up
salty snacks, other things.
And so there's sort of, anecdotally,
a lot of that sense that we are going
to get these kind of spillover effects.
So people often talk about the fact that
milk gets stored in the back of the store.
Why, because people buy
it very frequently, and
having it in the back of the store makes
them walk past a lot of other categories.
And hence, they might pick up other
things that they didn't plan on
buying on their way.
And so you could imagine that
advertising does something very similar.
If advertising allows me to divert
traffic to other parts of the store, then
maybe products I pass on that way are also
going to end up in my purchase basket.
And so that was something that we
weren't usually able to observe.
[MUSIC]
So for a store manager, the good news here
is that advertising is quite effective
beyond just the individual
product being advertised.
So what we find is that, when you
advertise a particular brand of beer,
sales go up in the beer
category as a whole.
And that increase comes partly
from the advertised brands, but
also goes beyond that.
So some consumers presumably
just pick up on the fact
beer is being advertised today.
They get reminded of I want to buy beer,
and
hence we see an increase in beer sales.
And that's beyond the individual
product being advertised.
At the same time we also find
that the effect stops there.
So to the extent that stores might have to
hope that driving more people beer isle
through advertising will then spin over
in to higher sales for salty snacks, or
other categories that are stocked nearby,
we find no evidence for that whatsoever.
So we think stop at category level, but
they go beyond the individual
product being advertised.
And so hence as we think about
allocating advertising budget,
thinking about effectiveness on
the level of the product category,
rather than the more narrow product
level or the broader store level,
seems to be the right way to
tackle that managerial decision.
[MUSIC]